ahead of monday's game at allegiant
stadium you'll spot raider nation in the
sky today allegiant airlines unveiled a
new plane designed with fans in mind
hector mejia live at mccarran airport
with a look hey hector
well the raiders brand is now soaring
through the clouds to the left we have
allegiance new passenger plane there
covered in silver and black we're told
it's only been in service for a week and
already touched ground in 12 different
cities
so look allegiant airlines says the
one-of-a-kind jet is designed to capture
the spirit and strength of raider nation
the plane will be based in las vegas
bringing an estimated hundreds of
thousands of fans to the valley took
about a week to paint it at a small
airport in victorville the silver and
black paint matches the team's helmets
you see it come out here and see how
perfect it is i mean it is men and women
and stencils and different layers of
paint that go on and what pops out is
this bold beautiful plane there's been
planes where they put a little logo on
but there's never been a plane that is
just washed in the iconic silver and
black like this one it's not only
different for us i think it's different
than what's been done around the league
because of how closely the companies are
working together that was las vegas
raiders president dan ventrell who took
the opportunity to remind fans to go
ahead and download the clear app before
game day that's what the team will be
using to check fans vaccination status
before they're allowed to go inside a
legion stadium
once you upload your vaccination
information to the clear app it's good
for the rest of the season they also
will have vaccinations on the spot in
case you want to get one on game day
reporting from mccarran airport hector
mejia 8 news now